okay so hypergamy basically means that
like girls are always trying to like
find the next next thing
so like basically in the red pill um
they don't think like girls can actually
like love guys the way that guys can
love girls because a girl will only love
a guy like
that's like the best she can get but if
she has a better option like that makes
more money is more attractive is like
just a better all-around option she'll
leave her current like boyfriend or
husband for them
oh
i have a little sketch do you think
that's true or false
um i don't think it's
true in every case but i think that's
possible yeah would you say like
would you say like what percentage of
girls do you think are like that
i don't know okay no this is just
burgers just like yeah it's not exactly
like they're not expecting you to like
have stats ready to go i'm just gonna
explain concepts to you and just like
from what you've seen
talking to your like friends you can
just say if you think it's true
i know like i just like
they want to like i don't know they like
being
like in a relationship i feel like so i
feel like they're not like looking to
leave because
i know they're always heartbroken when
you're broken up with yeah yeah no i
think so um
i don't okay this is one analogy that
i actually thought was really true
i feel you're not actually not you but i
have a lot of friends um
that i feel like they have like an x
that they just like can't get over and
they call it like a widow
and it basically means like the one guy
they like pair bonded to so that
basically means like before like
evolutionarily like typically you're
with one person
um or like they paired on to one guy
that like takes care of them yeah so
um and then it like ends
and like those girls that can't get over
them because i've seen girls like in new
relationships that like are still
thinking about like the last guy i could
i could see that like as being a thing
yeah
that's what i think too
um no i definitely have people that like
fill it or they'll like compare new
people to their ex yeah
but i think it's like there's kind
there's a limit though like after so
many years they kind of like forget
about that you know what i mean kind of
get done with it yeah
five thank you so much for the um
for the donation five dollars
you guys have good reaction
um okay what do you think about cheating
would you be able to work it out with
someone that cheated on you um
no
because i hold grudges like no other
um so they'd like anytime they'd make me
mad i'd be like
well you cheated your whole life
well because the whole um they have a
candy store analogy this is what someone
wants to explain to you
so basically like girls can hook up with
guys like have sex from like the age of
16 ish on you know yeah some some even
younger some earlier with like or older
some younger whatever okay um
so
i'm fine seriously
you can't you can't read the comments
okay
like that
yeah you can't read the comments too
like you can't
let them get to you i mean i'm not i'm
not worried about it okay
no it's like um but anyways so
she like
talked about the candy store analogy
okay so basically the candy store
analogy is like can't sex is candy and
girls get it right away but most guys
don't have access to sex till their late
20s early 30s
um because that's like when economically
they built themselves up as a guy like
to the point a girl wants to date them
okay so if you get married like before
then they think that like
girls should put up with cheating
basically
yeah i know
because like it's not fair to the guys
because like now at 35 they finally put
out their money right they got to the
gym for five years did all this stuff
now they get to have sex with a lot of
people so why would they only settle for
one well then why did they get married
if they don't
yeah that's what i would say i don't
know well don't get married then
this is oh this it only pertains to like
the top 10 percent of guys like jay-z
like
like super rich guys
i just feel like they shouldn't get
married but if someone like
i know like if someone
like
if like if someone got married to them
and they cheated that's like their
choice if they want to stay with them or
not like
personally i wouldn't but then also i
feel like there's certain people that
you kind of expect to cheat yeah don't
marry them if you're not looking for
that yeah
um so they're saying that marriage is
for kids
but this is this is what's interesting
to me because they always say things
like men are only as loyal as their
options that's a really common phrase in
the mannose sphere um and it's super
common for them to like believe that
cheating is different for men and women
which i actually think on some level it
is
like emotionally like versus physically
um like a guy will hook up with a girl
and i think it can actually mean nothing
i think that's harder for girls some
girls can do it but i don't i think
that's like the exception rather than
the rule okay okay did you feel true or
false
um
i don't know because i feel like
i feel like it's changed now at least
with like our generation because a lot
of my friends
like
are literally like they're not really
worried about
being in a relationship or they're just
like dating around and like not
too worried about it but i do like some
people can't do that like some girls are
yeah like they get mad if a guy's
talking to other girls even if they're
not even dating they're just like
hooking up yeah um
i this is like the way i see it i have
like seen a couple exceptions but i
think girls like become like that
because like
they're like older and like they've
hooked up with so many guys like each
one becomes less like
oh you know like but like a lot of the
girls i've seen that have like become
like that didn't start like that but
there's a few exceptions i can think of
yeah um would you say that's like true
fall like you can say like freely if you
agree or disagree i don't know i don't
care either way no i think it's easier
for girls to get attached but i
think that also
says something really distracting oh no
sorry
um
i think
girls get more attached
in short term
i think long-term guys get more attached
yeah that's a man of concept yeah that's
true but um i think girls get more
attacks short term but i also think like
there are more girls than people think
that like really
aren't looking just to like date one guy
and sleep with one guy like i think they
want to see their options first too
before like committing at least like a
lot of like my friends that i know
yeah
no that's funny said the
um
the thing about girls get more attached
immediately and guys get more attached
long term because i agree with that yeah
because i think a lot of times girls
will tell guys like what they need and
communicate that and a lot of guys just
like don't do it yeah and then like the
girl gets so annoyed over time she like
leaves they call this hyper to me but
sometimes like i've seen really because
they think it's like hypergamy to the
point um
that the girl's just looking for the
next best option and i have seen that
but i've also seen like
girls that like tell guys over and over
again what they want and then they don't
do it well that's what my roommate's
relationship was is like she told him so
many times like what she wanted
and then um
he just like never did it and then when
she left she was like right leaving
she's like we literally talked about
this
no
like he was so confused
um what are you talking about but it's
interesting because the menosphere seems
to think like
men um like don't have a biological like
girls have a younger biological clock
would you feel like that's true if you
want to have kids yeah because i think
it's like dangerous and you get close to
40. like yeah yeah
um which men can father kids like later
like so 60s it's like wild yeah but i i
think that most like guys biological
clock is like 40 because i think a guy
over 40 looks kind of weird if he
doesn't have a wife and kids
like 40 to 45 if you're still going to
the clubs and stuff like i'm like oh
that's like crazy
people don't want to have kids at 50
like
you know how old you would be when like
yeah and graduate
school
yeah
um
it is a dolly sorry i moved recently and
it was um
yeah i moved recently and my boss helped
me and brought it
um
and uh really like you can't have more
kids i just
watching my dad and how like tired he is
yeah and he's he'll always say like he
wishes he didn't have as many kids
i'm like dad you didn't you you don't
want us to exist like well my dad used
to be like i my dad used to be way
better at skiing than me and now that
he's in his 50s i can like beat him so
it's like melted in the car
what is it what she wants a reasonable
and is she giving in return oh i want a
reasonable okay what are your let's talk
about your requirements for a guy
okay how tall does he have to be for you
to date him and how tall are you
um i'm 5'6
um
i don't know i feel like i'm not like
too picky on the height i do like when
they're taller than me though yeah like
for cuddle reason
yeah but what's like what's the minimum
the minimum well i know i think damian
was like five nine like you're saying
your minimum six two guys my minimum
no actually like her ex boyfriend of
four years yeah i don't think i've
actually dated anyone like over
six
but okay yeah maybe six months would you
date a guy that's um five seven
maybe yeah so five sevens like iffy five
five nine is like more where your
preference is yeah i i'd say like
five eight to six two i guess i don't
know i don't want them super tall
um
okay and then what
is there a minimum like money
requirement that like clearly you
probably wouldn't date a guy dating or
making 25 000 a year
i'm i'm not worried about money as long
as they can take care of themselves okay
because i
um
i don't
like like i
yes
keep talking i'm reading it i'm gonna
ask you the questions
um no i don't have a minimum money
requirement as long as they can take
care of themselves because like i have
my [ __ ] together and i'd rather have
some of their shittily okay um so you
would you care if you did like 50 50
would that be fine with you that's what
you did in your last relationship right
thanks for joining me yeah um i think 50
50 is like for dating and stuff yeah
yeah i think that's fine um i definitely
gifts are not my love language so i
actually don't really
like when people like i don't really
care for when people buy me gifts
because i buy myself whatever i want so
i'm not so
i'm not i feel if we go on a date or
something i wouldn't mind doing 50 50 or
you pay one time and i pay one time
but
um
i don't know
as long as i can how old would you date
35 maybe
up to 35 yeah okay
um
so so your requirements is
like ish 5'7 and up
would you say
like i'd say forty five thousand and up
because that's like when you can take
care of yourself like thirty thousand
you can't really yeah maybe around here
i don't know but yeah like forty five
thousand and up for income and then um
what's the third thing i said
high oh and age so under 35
yes i have to say i mean i'm not super
picky and all these i'm really anxious
yeah it's a bad state they always they
always say like girls have these like
super crazy requirements
and
you know i would say like i was probably
the most picky of all my friends but i
was so picky i know i was
i was so picky but i didn't even have
like i didn't even think my requirements
were crazy because it was just like this
is like i would say i'm a little bit
more lenient now but when i was younger
it was like
um i wanted the same politics same
religion
taller than me
um motivated
yeah driven i didn't care about money i
just wanted them like driven
i think that's it right and then like
somewhat in shape
yeah i just i think the main thing was
um a lot of times you didn't give
like certain guys second chances because
no i didn't i was actually like you just
decided right away that it was not gonna
work yeah
well because i'd say oh like they didn't
have that one thing yeah but then like i
don't know the older you get you kind of
realize how stupid that is well everyone
has their flaws it's like people are
awkward on first dates too yeah and i
didn't
i don't know i was so lost in dating
though um before
let's see oh gosh
you smell cap on the
it's like having a money issue
that's what they they like never believe
girls
her boyfriend made less than her of four
years guys
um
okay wait
just to base pill
they don't want to have kids in your 40s
and 50 they agree okay especially in
this society
i should do a live music reaction no
this is going to be a red pill
conversation that's what i labeled it
this guy's just really just like he
doesn't like my answers
no they never do like that's the thing
you have to understand like with the red
pill like no matter what you say they
get mad like seriously
and like and even we don't have to date
dude yeah i know
but and i don't know why i don't know if
it's because we symbolize like
like
the average to cute girls that reject
them all the time so they get mad when
we say like we would reach out you know
what i mean yeah i don't know what it is
but it's just like
people people get so mad on the red pill
and i had to like train myself to just
not listen to it because they're so mean
they're like so mean like they'll be
like oh she's just a four like
oh how much i have deadlifts okay let me
tell you i used to be really strong
um i used to be able to deadlift
220 for five consistently
but um i've been struggling so
i haven't been lifting as much has she
cheated no you've never cheated on a
boyfriend no i don't
i feel like cheating is i don't know
it's kind of [ __ ] up i don't know
no
i i wouldn't have a reason i mean
unless
you're really unhappy
well they said what would the reason be
if you did yeah
they don't understand we're reading the
chat
why did you just yeah i
[Music]
well okay but this is the this is the
thing though in the um they consider
having guy friends cheating because they
think you're taking like emotional
oh
like stuff from guys but go go get the
ice cream go see i'm gonna entertain the
chat well well